you say you're good at keeping plot
secrets of things but you were a bit
loose lipped about the plot for Star
Trek to one one person yeah who I
thought deserved to know
and that was Stephen Hawking we were
into our third Margarito I think and I
decided to tell him and he literally
apart from the agents who told me the
news and the people who employ me were
the only people that were supposed to
know so yeah I told him
Wow did he tell anyone else now here's
the thing the late Professor Hawking's
work into the nature of space and time
yeah inspires us here on the show a lot
and we often earth new evidence of time
travel on the show for instance we've
outed Daniel Radcliffe as a time
traveler twice we found Daniel again in
another era there he is
we also had Justin Timberlake he showed
up in Newcastle as a ruffian and now we
can exclusively reveal Benedict
Cumberbatch is also a time traveler here
he is in the 1920s
crazy
you made someone very happy in the 1920s
looking in a mirror Graham where did I
get those bangs from look at that we got
if you want we can recreate the look if
you want to I could I say I'm glad you
said yes because someone went to a lot
of trouble to make this yeah okay okay
well to honor that I must wear it okay
there we go you do that bit you're so
dumb I sell to hurt you okay
ready do it where do I look where do you
look camera five there there yeah okay
[Applause]
[Music]
you